de de la perspective allemande c'est
clairement un référendum sur l'Europe h
mais été le principal clivage de cette
campagne en plus hein oui mais je je je
peux bien croire et ça harmonise avec la
perspective allemande que les Français
la majorité des Français
reste résolu à continuer avec le projet
européen ouais vous êtes sûr jean-catrem
parce qu'après tout on voit bien que et
Quentin nous l'expliquait à l'instant on
a quand même quasi un électeur sur deux
qui est qui est qui a été intéressé en
fait par un projet potentiellement
eurosceptique voire europhobe euh on a
parlé frxit quand même on est quand même
sur les fractures du référendum de 2005
on a toujours pas réglé dans cette
campagne vous avez raison les fractures
sont toujours là bon on peut toujours se
consoler en disant que en 2005 c'tait 55
% pour le nom et là finalement bah les
partis eurosceptiques europhobes sont à
moins de 50 % donc c'est déjà un peu
rassurant alors maintenant au second
tour là je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec N c'est que là on deux deux deux
projets de société totalement différents
qui s'opposent ça permet de clarifier
les choses on a un projet néofasciste
face à un projet républicain un projet
de fermeture face à un projet
d'ouverture un projet anti-européen face
à un projet pro-européen donc là les
Français vont pouvoir dire clairement ce
qu'ils veulent